oh
we're back with minecraft baby the new
update is out you can finally finally
you can go underneath 64. the whole
thing we wanted from the first update
and goddammo is disappointed i have not
played in so long look at all this oh
god is it still working
is my automatic sorting system still
functioning
it sounds like it
oh god it's laggy though
i got way too much red stuff going on
i don't know what i was thinking to be
honest
how could i ignore dark sven dark sven
hello dark sven roams here
it's good to see you man
yeah you wanna go with me
bonky oh the whole family me
let's go
that two fps i love it man hold up i
gotta i gotta have a little lookie it's
been a while since i looked at the world
oh yeah i built those i can build them
higher now right that was my whole thing
maybe that should be the first thing i
test because i wanted to look like
planets let's go up to it
so this is uh
ah damn this looks so cool
ah okay let's
hey look
i spent so much time on this
let's not forget that it's in hardcore
mode as well so i can't actually
you know what let's do that i don't want
to actually die good to know that my uh
my workers
my employers are working hard in the
amazon factory
they're still doing their job i like
that i like that a lot it lags so much
less up here when there's not a bunch of
stuff happening
sven get out of here you could die
careful
oh my god
all right so now we're in
we should be able to build higher
we can
you can build higher now
i don't know why this is cool this is
cool
yeah this is cool
height limits is 319.
it's not that much uh it's not that much
different
but for someone that likes to have stuff
in the sky i say that's really cool that
you can build that much higher i'm
definitely gonna build stuff with that
oh i can't wait oh that's gonna be so
cool oh i'm so excited yes
oh look i'm pretty my face is at night
dude that's going to look sick
i mean it does
really look sick hell yeah oh dude i
love my bass yes burn
iron farm chinese our iron farm 2 fps it
did not used to lag like this
right dark sven you're looking extra
dark today i gotta say man
all right let's put these back i want to
prepare for our uh underground adventure
i mean i think i have everything i need
yeah i'm always prepared i played
minecraft too much like i
i would say i played it
all right let's go oh yeah it's down
here isn't it let's be careful not to
pull
that was unnecessarily dangerous okay
here
this is like my mind shaft
hey sven you're coming with me
it's really not that fast now i think
about it i guess it's because i don't
have the
the buff why don't i have the buff oh
god the frame rate is so much better
here i love it
this is what i'm talking about
oh we hit lava careful sven we're at
nine pivotal moment oh this is it
we're boldly going where no one in this
world has gone before sven do not jump
in the lava i'm serious oh god you're
right there yeah that's right stay there
oh so now it's cobblestone it used to be
oh wait what's that
ah careful saying careful
what is that
cobbled deep slate so that's a new block
then
so instead it used to be uh whatever oh
my god this is huge man i can't wait
okay we're going under oh this is oh i'm
so excited
this is all i wanted
no stinking axle models they suck i'm
joking so we've got a brand new block i
have no idea what it does
maybe you can melt it i i look forward
just check it out
oh that's another type of block
tooth
that means tough in swedish that has to
be intentional so we're minus one now
that's so cool
we get gold and sh oh sick
whoa oh here it begins
that's so cool it's man i'm gonna dark
sven i know you're super epic but i'm
gonna leave you here because this is too
dangerous oh man i'm so hyped this is
high when i first play minecraft i i'm
an a minecraft veteran thank you
i was so hyped to see how far down you
could go and i was so disappointed that
you couldn't dig that deep
so now that they updated it at last
should i check out that chasm should i
just jump down here is that that's like
feels like a bad idea
is there anything down here oh
oh zombies okay i don't know why i was
you know what i am missing about what if
we put a water ladder here
hello
we're going i'm going down dark sven
if i don't make it out alive
just know i love you man
oh careful
is that a creeper did i hear a creeper
i ain't dying
this is not my first rodeo
yeah
oh there you are
i ain't taking no chances
i'm too powerful to die from some
stinking
oh god you're so annoying
this looks so cool this is this is iron
right yeah they updated that fine
new recipe
deep slate gold ore okay
what are they doing what are you guys
talking about in there get out of
here so i know there's uh there's a new
enemy to watch out for
it's supposed to be really dangerous
and i definitely don't want to run into
him unprepared oh i get the buff here
cool maybe i should stick around here
then uh i forgot to bring look at so
organized
so which floor are we on -17 i think it
goes down to 64.
red what is that
it looks good i like those blocks
all right i'm heading back i do like
that i have the buff here
i think i have lighter falling what is
that
[ __ ]
oh
almost died it's whatever
minus 20 so we can still go down a lot
dude oh maybe i'll go back up i'll go
back up we explored this game
sven
dark sven i'm back
struggling to
get back on
board neither hand dark sven i put the
water too low god damn it
okay dark sven
journey continue
into hell
oh hella comfy dude
oh yes
oh so comfy i'm going to spend hours i
purposely have not looked into what the
update is too much because i wanted to
just explore i think that's the fun
no need to tell me oh come
damn it
i'm a minecraft expert okay
sven oh it's okay omar come
oh careful here sven left trap
oh then i just walk in circles great
good job me
all right we go deeper
eight diamonds
[Laughter]
i only got one do i not have fortune
what the heck this cheap ass place dude
doesn't matter how many hours you have
in minecraft you still get hyped for
diamonds that's just how it is
we are now minus 26 so not that deep
still i'm getting me
oh god you're really right in my face
dude dark sven is kind of cringe not
gonna lie prefer a real
uh oh okay
did you guys see that
i thought jesus said hello or something
i think it's my shader doing the
glitches i got so mad at mojang for
almost getting me killed because of my
shaders glitching
uh 53 baby
can you yeah i need some space dark sven
okay you're a little bit clingy okay
oh my god dude
he's worse than edgar darksvin is the
worst of the multiverse men oh there it
is the new bottom
we found it
all right minus 60 i guess 64 60 yeah
okay cool
now we dig straight
until we find chasm
oh
god dark sven did you hear that
super evil sounds i love it
this is gonna be the new way to farm
diamonds maybe
like are diamonds more rare here
i don't know
you know what i don't need this famous
last words
iron
gold
[Music]
i just realized what it sounds like
where are the new bio minecraft i've
been looking for 20 minutes
i want to explore and have fun where is
it i wish sven could like help at least
like maybe sniff out some canyons and
stuff like that
you slaves
you will never be what he was i'm full
god damn it
push me again sven push me again see
what happens keep pushing me see what
happens keep pushing me see what happens
that's what i thought
jesus christ does that mean you can go
deeper in the nether
i don't think about it
stop it you smell
when's the last time you oh sorry
oh my god can i find anything
hold on
the warden mob has been delayed
oh that's cool
that's cool
then what's the point
there's no sense of danger isn't sven
i bet you delayed the update didn't you
yeah
what am i digging for now there's
nothing exciting i'm just digging for
nothing why do they keep doing this
mojang
why
you did ab tuff i do like the tooth
oh is that the warden no that's not into
something okay
that is a creepy sound though i'm not
gonna lie dark spin
i'm a little freaked out oh
[Music]
could there be a warden in here sven
oh sven sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
everyone is sorry i don't have meat
actually i'll use my bow from now on
[Music]
no
no uh
[Music]
it's your fault
where are you stupid
you made me kill you killed ducks fan
not me oh god you saw it it was on
camera
oh i love dark son he was the best
starks fan he was the best fan of the
multiverse
ah
i hate this update
he was like a father to me he would tell
me bedtime stories dark sven god
darksvan
why would he run in front of my ball
he would always be in my face all the
time it's not my fault i take no
responsibility for the death and injury
of i was just dead no
oh dark span
darksvan
i will kill the warden darkson in your
honor if i can find anything interesting
in this
[Music]
darkness all we got is come on the walls
thanks moe jane
i'm going back home man this sucks
it's not the same if i have no one to
talk to
oh [ __ ] oh
god
gosh it
ah
okay we're fine
and we're good
all right we're going back up i guess
back to two frames per second
i was i could have just built one of
them but i was like no i'm gonna be a
four
and i was like no i'm building eight
actually
are they getting enough
yeah i think i think they are
i think i think that was
uh
where's my elevator here again
bonky
i got bad news man
dark sven didn't make it
i know
he was like a father to you i know
dark spend rooms here
ah
the memories that we had together man
how you doing dark sven
that's a sad man
i don't know if they have a place to go
but i don't care i don't care
you know what
i'm going on a journey
i need to see that something else is out
there
if they had anything in this update
cloud city
we've got two alpacas making love that's
awesome thanks mojang thanks for killing
my dog mojang i hope you understand this
is what you did darksven hated flowers
[ __ ] you flowers
you're so cool and dark
it's another dark spin
dark's been reincarnated as sheep
wow
dark sven returns
come
come i'll take you home
dark friend
shy
here dark son i got you meat
just like i promised
he loves it
oh there's a city here
never realized that's so nice dark fan
looks fine i forgot he's not an actual
dog and doesn't follow me
he's like a father to me i can't
i mean he is a lose of course he follows
me come here ducks man
look i found a town dark son isn't that
lovely what should i do with the town
bernie
okay you're the boss darksven don't say
i didn't warn you
dark sven it looks like
looks like something's going on ah dark
swan number two died
this is just not
he told me to burn i hate stop why does
everyone die this is [ __ ]
dark swin would have appreciated this
i got that pig dying
i'll burn this town in this honor
yeah go hide inside child
there's
you're safe inside oh
be serious i was gonna do my outro
well
this has been a show
thank you for watching like and
subscribe and you could win a billion
and i see you guys next time
brofist